cuál es el volumen de la caja arrastra
el cursor en la figura para girar la a
ver a mira esto está padrísimo podemos
hacer que gire la caja bueno queremos
calcular el volumen de esta caja de aquí
y observemos que todo está medido en
pies 3 pies 5 pies 6 pies de esta forma
si queremos determinar el volumen vamos
a necesitar de mente terminarlo en pies
cúbicos vale y bueno como ya vimos en un
vídeo para determinar el volumen de una
caja lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar las tres dimensiones que nos
dan en este caso son 3 5 y 6 entonces el
volumen sería 3 por 5 por 6 vamos a
realizar la operación 3 por 5 es 15 y 15
por 6 a ver si lo puedo hacer por aquí a
ver 15 por 6 es lo mismo que 6 por 10 o
sea 60 más 6 por 5 o sea más 30 60 más
30 es 90 entonces la respuesta sería 90
pies cúbicos vamos a ver si sí muy bien
correcto siguiente pregunta
y dice cuál es el volumen de la caja
arrastra el cursor en la figura para
girar la es exactamente lo mismo ahora
tenemos que hacer 8 por 3 por 2 pero
ahora las unidades son centímetros
entonces pues el volumen va a estar en
centímetros cúbicos cuánto nos quedaría
a ver sería 8 por 3 24 y 24 por 12 48
entonces la respuesta sería 48 muy bien